oh here's the spider-man meme that has
been slightly adjusted with the patriot
head on one spider-man and the houston
astros
asterisks on the other end hey guys i've
tried to ignore this as much as i can in
large part because i don't care about
baseball my first reaction when it came
up was this is a shot across the bow at
all pro sports as legalized gambling is
spreading if you have scandals like this
that's the quickest way to have congress
up your rear end and or a prosecutor
looking for who he or she can put behind
bars when this thing happens because
it's affecting the hard-earned money
that millions of americans will be
wagering on sports but beyond that you
know as more and more comes out about
the astros sign stealing scandal that
was going on for a year or longer that
involved possibly
wearable technology that was as low-tech
as it gets a buzzer that allegedly was
letting the batters know the location of
the pitch and major league baseball said
they found no evidence of it i don't
know how hard they look for it i mean
here's my big takeaway from this and
maybe this is one of the things that
helps football
there are so many people who are
constantly watching football games
scrutinizing everything they see looking
for cheating scandals thanks to
everything that's happened over the last
15 years involving the patriots and
other teams then i don't think anyone in
football would get away with this
because the moment something came across
the tv screen that looked remotely amiss
we would hear about it on twitter
reporters would follow up on it there
are so many people who are watching and
listening and thinking about what's
going on in football at any given moment
it never would have gone undetected for
two years am i off base big cat no i
don't think you're off base i i i would
agree that as football fans i think when
you watch games on sunday and your team
loses the first thing you think of is
how did the ref screw us over and the
second thing you think of is how did the
other team cheat to win this game so as
football fans we're probably wired to
always be have our guard up and wonder
hey how are they doing something that is
against the rules the only thing i could
think of mike when when i was sent you
know the rundown for today was was
lester hayes and stickum being outlawed
and then guys using stickum you know
jerry rice admitted to using stickum
past the time when it was outlawed so
that type of thing but that was 30 40
years ago and it's tough to get away
with things now so it would have to be
some kind of
uh equipment thing but it would be very
tough for you you're exactly right for
two years to pass without someone saying
hey this looks odd why aren't we fixing
this well yeah well well like i ask you
guys first of all it's a bad look and i
mean what the first year they got caught
cheating it was what banging on the
trash can right somebody was watching
the video of the signals and then if
they banged on the trash can they knew
it was an off speed pitch you know
whether they wore this you know thing on
their chest or their shoulder that
vibrated uh or sent you know pulsing
signals to to tell you what pitch was
coming i don't know you're right mike
that hasn't been proven yet it's
certainly a little like suspect when you
see guys like altuve who hits a
game-winning homer against my new york
yankees and it's like the happiest
moment of the year
and he's saying he's holding his shirt
saying don't rip my jersey off in like a
really big moment i don't think those
are the things you think of in like the
biggest moment of the year so that's
shady let alone all the people that have
been connected along with it but what is
comparable to it in the nfl to where you
could say it right like what is what is
it like would it be the opposing team be
able to listen to the coach quarterback
conversation absolutely that would be
the one yeah
it's it's intercepting the coach
quarterback conversation and having a
mechanism to communicate what you are
gleaning
immediately to 11 members of the defense
right and i think i think that's why
it's easier in baseball for something
like this to happen yeah because you
only need to let one guy know right it's
pitcher versus batter you let the batter
know what the pitch is going to be
you're set i think it's much harder and
that was one of the knocks on the whole
spygate thing like how in the hell did
the patriots have a system where they
had in advance videotaped defensive
coaching signals so they could crack the
code in real time when they play that
team later
so that they would know what the defense
is going to be and somehow they're
processing all of that and factoring it
into their play call and getting it to
tom brady i never did understand how
they were able to do all those things in
that limited window of time but for
baseball it's a hell of a lot easier you
see the sign you bang on the can you
pulse the thing if there is something
that people were wearing to let them
know the location of the pitch and it's
clean and it's simple and it makes me
wonder big cat how widespread it is you
know the big push back against the
bounty punishment against the saints
eight years ago was everybody is doing
this why are you picking on one team
i can't help but wonder yeah yeah i
can't help but wonder how deep this
rabbit hole goes for baseball then are
they going to bother to try to go down
it well i think there's also a cultural
difference in the two sports in that uh
baseball has a culture of cheating and
you know the steroid era the greeny era
there's you know spit balls everything
that has happened baseball has always
had that underlying hey if we're playing
in the gray area if we're doing things
to try to get an advantage here it's
part of the game it's just part of the
game the unwritten rules of baseball
yeah there's no really unwritten rules
of football it's played a little more
straight up so i that is that also
factors in here when you're talking
about could this ever happen in the nfl
i don't think so i think baseball
baseball if you go through the history
of baseball it just jumps from one
somewhat ski you know cheating scandal
to to the other every single 20 years it
seems like something pops up where it's
like all right well we got to fix this i
mean baseball think about this guys
baseball juices their own balls major
league baseball juice their balls
like so so there's it's in the culture
of the game that these things happen and
that things are kind of funky sometimes
and and results make people say hey whoa
this is weird i don't know what's going
on so i it could never happen in
football to this extent no no i don't
think it could happen to football in
this extent too though in football i
feel like you would cheat during a game
to help yourself out maybe the next game
to understand calls or oh you know you
know we had our defensive tackle miced
up and we heard all the calls the
quarterback made at the line of
scrimmage and what the center called so
now when they make that call we know
they're doing this and protection and
our linebacker can maybe send the the
blitzers from the other side whatever it
may be
um and i i'm always a big fan of juice
balls there's no doubt about that it was
a fun year in baseball all right but the
other thing is
like you guys do agree this is like hey
i'm off like sign stealing like big cat
said it's always been part of baseball
stealing sign but we're all in agreement
that this is like this goes above and
beyond and this is not good for the game
right i mean yeah this is going too far
for baseball because i hear some people
in the media trying to say this has
always gone on and this is part of the
sport a little bit like what you were
trying to reference there big cat and i
want to go no it's 20 20 and we have a
lot of technology at our disposal it's a
little different now i just want to make
sure we're on the same page yeah yeah i
agree i think it's the worst scandal for
baseball since the black sox that to the
extent that it tainted a full season a
world series championship
and i think and i think baseball is
being very careful about how much they
admit to they need to acknowledge that
they need to do something about it but
they can't make it seem too big because
it ultimately hurts baseball if it is
too big you know there are some who
think they should strip that world
series championship i think that makes
it an even bigger deal it's brought down
careers it's created a major problem but
i think baseball politically and from a
pr standpoint and from a we want people
to still show up to our games standpoint
they're trying to walk a fine line there
so look why not and let's think about
this because i say all the time as it
relates to football here we are a
hundred years after the creation of the
nfl and we still determine whether or
not a team has gained a first down with
two sticks and 10 yards of chain link in
between them
why isn't there a more
technologically feasible way
of communicating between pitcher and
battery yeah that doesn't involve a guy
sneaking a couple of fingers down in his
in his crotch to try to let only the
pitcher see what the pitch is going to
be right why not have a radio from the
bench why not do something that
eliminates the possibility that signs
can be stolen i like it mike you're an
innovator i kind of wish that you were
uh you know this was pro pro baseball
talk so that you could just have a field
day with this scandal because you would
the one last thing that i think baseball
is doing very deliberately and it's
obvious that is happening is they're
making sure this stays at a manager
level they're not letting any players
kind of get implicated and the players
have been implicated but they're not
going to suspend players it doesn't seem
like right now and that bothers me a
little bit because it seems like a very
player driven scandal like the players
are asking for this the players are
benefiting from this and the managers
are the ones that are getting fired i
you know it is a it is a black eye on
baseball here i think they will maybe
lose a couple casual fans like mike
florio like that's really what it is
baseball be careful you might lose mike
florio as a huge uh baseball fan
that happened that happened 28 years ago
when the
uh braves beat the pirates in game seven
and somehow sid bream scored from second
and barry bonds didn't throw him out
that was the moment i walked away um but
but but back to the original point they
need to be very concerned about this as
legalized gambling spreads once we get
to a critical mass of states somewhere
between 35 and 40 this is a big deal
because now it didn't happen in 2017
because gambling wasn't legal so anybody
who lost their bets too bad it's illegal
gambling nobody's going to do anything
about it but if a scandal like this
happens after you've got people who are
plunking down money on the outcomes of
these games and we find out that the
outcomes are being skewed by blatant
cheating a widespread cheating scandal
that went on undetected for months if
not years
that's when congress creates an agency
that has oversight over all professional
sports in the ncaa that's when congress
and state legislatures pass laws that
allow easy prosecutions for cheating in
sports that's when
every sports league has a major major
problem on its hand and its reality
changes in a very dramatic and negative
way guys yeah no doubt about it i mean
listen i'm a big baseball fan and the
yankees are my favorite team in all of
professional sports this bothers me it
does as a baseball fan it really does
and i i really feel like i just kind of
got over within the last few years of
the whole steroid scandal that really
bothered me mike you know you've heard
me speak out a lot of times about guys
and peds in the nfl it's cheating it's
against the law for one it's a horrible
example to set for young kids so that
bothered me now we're going to do this
this is next like next level cheating
and mike i think your point listen
you've had two great points sky judge in
the nfl ever since the saints rams
debacle in the championship game last
year and i'm with you they need some
like manager to picture and and catch
your
type of communication take these signals
away start making these guys hit balls
so they don't know what's coming anymore
like you know that's a bunch of bs it
really bothers me actually
well it's hiding in plain sight the
solution is there we'll see if they
implement it but they need to prevent
this and the other sports need to learn
from it so they don't have similar
issues in the future but i think the nfl
is safe because of past cheating and
because there are so many people who are
constantly looking for that alternative
explanation for their team losing other
than their team just isn't very good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports